bring in Kevin Frazier he covers the
entertainment world like nobody else for
entertainment tonight and had red carpet
last night pre-show post-show parties
how are you Kevin and I'm magical you
know I mean look I was trained by you I
know how to I know how to go go you know
long and strong and and make it in to
work the next morning okay who did you
talk to last night that maybe you got a
little bit more than you thought you
know what I'll tell you this talking to
Glenn Weiss who is the director of the
Oscars he told us a few secrets about
what was going on with Bradley Cooper
and Lady Gaga's performance right and he
said that Bradley directed before he had
a heavy hand in directing the
performance because here's my thing when
Bradley and Lady Gaga performed shallow
and at the very end when they were
looking in each other's eyes they look
like they might kiss I'm thinking did he
direct that moment or is this real
because Gaga to look like she just
wanted to devour him and meanwhile just
a few feet away his ladylove Irina Shayk
the model who look starting on the red
carpet was sitting in the front row
now she jumped up and gave her you know
clapping standing ovation and someone
said she deserved a Best Supporting
Actress nom for be sitting between the
two of them and acting like everything
was cool but I thought that that was
fascinating that maybe Bradley directed
that moment and they decided to do that
close-up with the two of them looking in
their eyes um that was my that was one
of my favorite moments spike was on fire
on the red carpet boy was he on fire gia
was wearing those um those finger rings
from do the right thing yeah those ones
that says love and hate he was just so
height and of course he was so hype it
he jumped up on Samuel Jackson when he
won his uh when he won his Oscar can I
tell you who look spectacular Jennifer
Lopez that dress yeah but that's not a
shocker I I don't think I would have
gone with white if I have is Alex
Rodriguez well look I mean Alex has had
some interesting interesting outfits
okay but he's the guy when you are with
Jennifer Lopez you can take some fashion
risk because half the
people are looking at you you know this
is one of the few times in his life
where he's like an accessory
he's been the main guy all his life and
all of a sudden he becomes the accessory
and she shows up in this dress that's
all glass and people are losing their
minds they're like oh yeah dudes with
her I mean look I love a rod but he
might you know he'd be accessory for the
song Grammy Malik fell off the stage man
yeah so afterwards you know everybody's
taking pictures he's up on the stage he
falls off he holds on to his Oscar but
the paramedics come busting down there
because they're like oh my goodness we
got to make sure you're okay Beverly
Hills fine has come down and they check
them out and he was okay they sat him
down and he was okay and he went to the
governor's ball and you know afterwards
kicked it at some parties because look I
mean it's like a player getting taken
out of the biggest game of the year you
know you fall you hurt yourself and
you're like coach I'm not coming out
there was no way in hell he was not
gonna go out and celebrate the moment of
his life and that's what he did the best
party toughest party to get into a
Vanity Fair it was funny because uh
without a doubt Vanity Fair's the
toughest party to get into it there are
always private parties I mean my
favorite private party was always
Prince's Oscar party that he would have
every year he would perform all the
biggest stars would fight to get in it
used to be Madonna's before that but
then it turned into Prince's and I don't
think anyone has one up that party
because it was just magical you would
walk in the room and every big star was
there and they were all like little
children listening to Prince perform it
was the best party always of the evening
but um there was a you know there are a
lot of people who go to Vanity Fair and
a few sports folks they snuck in last
night I'll leave you with this in the
final 30 seconds could you take my
hirsch Allah Ali one on one looked like
he's incredible shape I think he would
give it to me and you so don't even
fantasize I know you're jumpers nice but
he would get he would give it to both of
us and by the way can I just say I
talked to spike about Zion yeah when he
was there I asked him if he jinx died on
he says you know you're the first person
to ask and
I immediately went home and checked the
back page of the New York Post the next
day because I thought that they were
gonna make me the jinx but he was like
Obama was there the Obama get an app
Kevin always great to talk to you Dan
always great to talk to you but I don't
think you would score on rehearsal a
finalist on let you know stuff don't
know he's a little bit dumb
stop your lack of sleep is affected he
might be drunk who knows thank you I am
watching and you know the Dan ants were
like did you know that he was a college
basketball player st. Mary's I'm like
yeah he's a role player got some run I'd
like to shoot with him you know say for
its it can set that up
bring him in got some run a little bit
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]